the GSB is a place that in the end is
really about the people it's about how
they come together as a community how
they engage and engagement of our
students faculty staff and alumni I
think has never been richer we had about
3,000 alumni from 40 different countries
come to the GSB last year that's a
record number one of the great strengths
of the school is the diversity of the
student body because the students learn
from one another they come from
consulting and Investment Banking of
course but also from high tech from
biotech from consumer products
we have about 15% who come from the
military non government or nonprofit
organizations we all come from different
backgrounds we all have different
talents and we're all searching for
different things and that really allows
the cohort to be supportive of one
another the GSB positively impacted my
career upon graduation I had a number of
different opportunities available to me
and according to the mantra change lives
change organizations change the world
I really felt gratified to have the
luxury to choose a course of action that
where I'd have the the greatest impact I
think something that makes the GSB
really unique is the interdisciplinary
nature of the culture here I was a joint
degree student at the GSB taking classes
in the School of Education and at the
Business School and it really changed my
life by being able to have a community
and network in both of those departments
give an incredible living learning
environment that we have established
between the Schwab residential center
and the knight Management Center most of
our MBA students want to be resident on
the campus to that end we are adding a
new 200 bed facility called Highland
Hall and respected to be open next
summer in time for the crop of students
who will come next fall one of the ways
that we equip our students to lead is
through the leadership curriculum that
we've been working on over the past few
years in a program that we call I lead
the coaching the leadership development
program HSB give me a chance to explore
my own leadership style and provide a
safe environment for me to do all sorts
of experiments with the leadership
skills I think the most interesting
thing about the faculty at the GSB is
that they really have a great mix of
academic and practical experience and so
you get to see both sides of an issue
over the past decade or so we have had a
concerted effort to increase the size of
our faculty while of course maintaining
our very high standards this past year
we had an exceptional recruiting year
hiring twelve new faculty members even
as we've hired so many great new faculty
we of course have to say goodbye to some
faculty who've been here for a while
this year Jim patell and my canon who
have served 40 and 39 years respectively
have decided to retire the
experimentation that we're doing with
online education in our executive
education programs is also providing us
with learning about how to apply those
techniques for our MBAs and other
students on the campus
we've had enormous emphasis in the last
few years on increasing the reach of our
content in order to make the content
more accessible we have done a full
revamp of our website in the past year
alone we had something like 10 million
visits through the website we've
increased the number of followers on our
various social media properties from
just 16,000 in 2011 to more than one and
a half million at the moment over the
past few years we pioneered a new
fellowship program the Africa Fellows
Program which helps us attract
extraordinary young men and women from
Africa they come here for the two years
of the MBA program and then are required
to go back for two years to their
continents so that they can take the
benefit of their education and have
impact in their communities back home
I'm so grateful to our alumni for all of
the support and for your volunteerism
it's your energy that makes your local
chapters what they are we love it when
you come into class when you recommend
students to us it's really this energy
this volunteerism the spirit of
connectedness that makes our alumni
community what it is so please come and
visit us reconnect with one another and
see what we've been up to lately